getting it more however we we've been
planning on this as a team managing
these sites
for when we're going to start to ramp
down and demobilize some of our assets
so there's no additional max vaccination
sites on the
on the table right now but there will be
uh
on the fifth of may we will be closing
this one here
transitioning the staff to convention
center and then using the extra
resources
to staff many strike teams and task
force components around the valley to do
smaller
locations like three to four or 500
people a day
cashman's last day is the fifth of may
and it's second doses only everything
else
everybody that gets a first dose now is
being scheduled for their second dose
at convention center
um
so the question is will the county
support and enforce vaccine
business businesses that choose to have
a vaccine so the private sector is well
within their right
to do whatever they want in order
to help us with mitigation efforts
i do support that in many instances i
said that
yesterday that you know edc
asked about coming and i said look i'd
like to see
if if it were up to me which it is not
um
people that have been vaccinated or
negative pcr tests
that is consistent because my
responsibility
is to ensure that our community is safe
and that we can keep the positivity rate
down
is
no not at all because we tracked the
first doses that we gave three and four
weeks earlier we knew that this week was
going to be very large
because if you back up to when
hospitality opened that was three weeks
ago so we got a big influx of people
from the hospitality in the restaurant
and this food service industry
so we knew our second shots are going to
be very high so those 7 700
7 700 shots that we gave in this
building on tuesday
three quarters of those were second
doses they were follow-ups
does that make sense
so what i would say is we also rely on
you the media to help
us uh get the message out to make our
community safer
so anytime that you can remind folks i'm
i have two people that call through
district b
every single day because some folks just
still
don't know how to get it they don't know
how to access it as much as
we try to as much as we all live it
every single day not everybody else does
so i rely on all of you in the media to
help me
get the message out there were some
folks
in the beginning that may had just had
covid they had to wait a time frame to
get it
we're going to go back out into the
neighborhoods as well
to provide additional options for folks
to come in
and get their vaccine but this is
consistent with the lull that we've seen
every single period that we opened a new
a new level going forward so
what i would tell you is it may be slow
today but it could be very busy tomorrow
it just really depends we're 24 7 town
people have different schedules and so i
don't want people to think that
there are not folks getting vaccines
because we're working hard every single
day to remind people that
we want to make our community as safe as
possible
so once we identify those sites and
schedule the dates they'll be put up on
the
health district website and we'll push
that out to the media but we have done
dozens and dozens of these since january
we've used hollywood rec center
pearson community center winchester
we've used county and city-based
community centers all over to do 250 to
300 people a day
with a smaller workforce and just be
more spread out in the community so
that's our plan going forward once we
condense these larger sites we will
saturate the areas that really need it
uh that you know have been maybe not
come to got their shot didn't want to
get a shot
try to just make it a little bit easier
for them to get to it these
megapods were to vaccinate the masses as
fast as we could you get the most bang
for your buck when you put 150 people
working a site you can do seven
to eight thousand but to do uh 300 you
still need 12 or 15
at the least and then when you you know
just get more efficiency
in the larger pods to get as many done
as possible then break off and pick up
the rest of the community with the
partnerships of the pharmacies
like cvs walgreens smith's and so forth
i don't know if the daily numbers will
be the same but we will definitely reach
people that have not been able to get
here or did not want to come
some people hate crowds i mean it's a
bad town to live in if you hate crowds
but
you know if you don't like crowds you
know this would be an opportunity to get
to a spot that's a little slower
as far as the pace
just just to follow up on the comments
from the chief
er the the main purpose of also a small
strike teams or vaccination size
is to strengthen our collaboration with
community-based organizations the the
faith community
and and the purpose is actually to bring
the church
closer to the people so they they we had
that
vaccine available closer in the
neighborhood
in an environment where they feel more
comfortable
okay we'll take one more question and
then we're gonna
i'm gonna head out and get my second
dose
she wants a clarification on when the
second doses are at this
site
um oh i don't have that date in my head
it'll be three weeks
it'll be three weeks from well we're
gonna continue to do first and second
doses here
first the second if you got a first dose
here today you're going to be scheduled
for your second dose at convention
center
second doses will stop here on may 5th
does that make sense
everything stops on may 5th yes yes
because when we we opened up to
hospitality we got
run over people wanted their shots and
three weeks from that day
is when they're coming back for their
second shot so we were really heavy
heavy busy the first day or two
with the hospitality group and then it
trickled down and we see it with every
tier
so same thing we knew that the
hospitality group was going to come back
for their second shots
we knew it was going to be busy we
talked about at the end of last week we
could see that we had 6 600
second doses booked already for tuesday
we knew it was going to be a big day
here
later in the week yes saturday is going
to be busy again not as busy as tuesday
but
wednesday thursday friday had smaller
numbers it does we do still fill up some
uh we have partners that are out there
trying to push the message to their
employees and
and their uh constituents to to get
people over here
but we knew we planned for it
absolutely thank you well uh first
all vaccines that have been approved for
let's say
uh receive emergency authorization
from the fda have been submitted to a
rigorous process
and uh johnson johnson is also part of
that
we we know that both pfizer
and moderna have been applied
already to millions and millions of
people in this country
and so far we haven't experienced
those severe adverse events
again going back to johnson and johnson
uh serious adverse events it is
important to mention that
we today we are talking about six cases
out of almost 7 million doses that are
being administered from that vaccine
and when you look at most of the
vaccines that are being offered
in a regular basis through the
immunization programs across the country
that that proportion is extremely low
but
still is is important because the the
fda
considered is a serious event and that's
why
they are doing their investigation thank
you
okay